Buongiorno Che cos'è quello
mi avrà visto
[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi benvenuti Bentornati su
Anita Stories oggi nuova Challenge super
pazza faremo un nascondino Ma bendati
anche io sarò bendata come sempre ci
saranno quattro round Se perdo per più
di due round Avrò perso la Challenge
vince chi trova prima l'altra persona
però da bendato Prevedo che questa
Challenge sarà un po' un disastro
[Musica]
Ehi andate via non è ancora iniziata la
Challenge
[Musica]
sicuramente non mi hanno sentito ma
almeno sono andati via ma ora Mettetevi
comodi prendete i Popcorn e lasciate un
mi piace entro cinque secondi cinque
quattro Tre due uno tempo scaduto se non
mi seguite ancora su Instagram andate a
seguirmi il nome Anita Stories andasse a
seguirmi anche su Tik Tok siete pronti
iniziamo subito la Challenge via
[Musica]
Ciao Guerrino Sei pronto a giocare il
nascondino anche tu
[Musica]
che ragazzi primo round la metto la
benda e vediamo chi entrerà da quella
porta
per ora non sento Nessun rumore strano
Spero di non sbattermi da nessuna parte
[Musica]
qua c'è il tavolo
magari mi nascondo sotto al tavolo
qua c'è il cuscino
c'è Merlino
il rumore da qualche parte qua deve
essere qua vicino
ho sentito una marea
[Musica]
preso ti ho
presa abbiamo vinto il primo round ho
preso Ice Cream perché mi ha tirato
qualcosa addosso e ho capito dov'era
prima round vinto
Ciao ragazzi secondo round c'è molto
vento Spero che mi sentiate bene Non so
chi sia il prossimo nemico il prossimo
cattivo iniziamo a bendarci e diamo via
al secondo round da che parte Andiamo
non è nessuno
sento un rumore
C'è qualcuno
[Musica]
preso preso
[Applauso]
Sì che ho preso vediamo
il coniglio abbiamo vinto il secondo
round passiamo ora al terzo round
[Musica]
questo terzo round è all'aperto vedete è
ancora più pericoloso perché Potremmo
sbatterci agli alberi o inciampare e
cadere nel fango Ancora non è comparso
nessuno comunque questa è la mia benda
Ti amo inizio al terzo round è difficile
sentire i passi perché c'è il rumore del
vento
un albero
sento dei rumori ma non so chi è
Granny
devo scappare Non so dove sta andando
Il problema è che credi già cieca quindi
riuscire comunque a trovarmi anche con
la benda
l'albero Ok
sono finite ad un cespuglio
rumore viene da dietro
no
[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi quarto e ultimo round
Apriamo la porta e vediamo chi ci
aspetta pronti via si sente qualcuno che
dorme devo mettere la mascherina
[Musica]
sembra che provengano da questa parte
questi
rumori
che Merlino
Questo è il divano
[Musica]
forse Merlino
Merlino
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho preso l'ombrello
vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
un cretino cretino
Vedi hai aiutato a catturare il lupo
bravissimo
[Musica]
Ma da dove è caduto questo cuscino
Che strano
[Musica]
Non c'è nessuno
Forse mi sono immaginata tutto
[Musica]
chi c'è c'è qualcuno
Da dove viene questa musica
la sentite anche voi
Vabbè Forse il vicino di casa che sta
suonando
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ah ok Ho capito forse di quelle tastiere
che suonano da sole avete presente
quelle che insomma fanno le musichette
da sole
Ok dimmi subito chi sei so benissimo che
c'è qualcosa che non va Chi sei Dimmi
che cosa vuoi da me
sapete che quando succedono queste
strane cose paranormali in casa vuol
dire che c'è qualche intruso
un biglietto bene
scopriamo pure che cosa ci aspetta Ma
come non ti ricordi di me il tuo nemico
più simpatico di tutti
l'Uomo Invisibile Ti avevo promesso che
sarei tornato e ora Trovami se ci riesci
e se non ci riesci
meglio che scappi Ok Cerchiamo subito un
nascondiglio sbrighiamoci Ma se non
avete ancora lasciato un mi piace Mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace se
questo video raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace
ci sarà un altro episodio con l'Uomo
Invisibile Mettetevi comodi prendete i
Popcorn iniziamo subito la Challenge Ok
ragazzi dobbiamo sbrigarci a scegliere
il primo nascondiglio l'Uomo Invisibile
potrebbe essere ovunque qua
mi nascondo qua dietro al divano
da qua riesco a vedere qualcosa
ovviamente non riesco a vedere L'uomo
invisibile ma magari riesco a vedere se
c'è qualche oggetto fluttuante o
qualcosa di strano Tenete gli occhi bene
aperti anche voi
[Musica]
Ok ragazzi sono scappata in studio Avete
visto l'Uomo Invisibile stavo spostando
i divani e le sedia per prendermi ma non
c'è riuscito ora devo subito trovare un
altro nascondiglio
[Musica]
C'è qualcosa di strano qui
aglio o c'è qualcuno che sta dormendo
sul letto lo vedete anche voi cioè c'è
una coperta e
lo so sembra che ci sia qualcuno sotto
che faccio alza la coperta potrebbe
essere rischioso Ma sì dai devo riuscire
io a trovare l'Uomo Invisibile così
vinco la Challenge
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa o no prova ad afferrarlo
c'è freddo No non c'è niente
maledizione
finché non trovo l'Uomo Invisibile e
finché lui non mi trova nessuno dei due
Avrà vinto la Challenge ma noi dobbiamo
vincere la Challenge quindi sbrighiamoci
Cerchiamo un posto in cui nasconderci Ho
un'idea c'è un posto in cui è molto
difficile che ci trovi col nostro
nascondiglio siamo nascosti dietro a un
tapis roulant Oh guardate chi c'è è
arrivato anche Merlino Ciao Merlino Mi
raccomando non devi far sapere all'uomo
invisibile che siamo nascosti Qui ok
Anzi magari tu con il tuo fantastico
fiuto da cane riesce a capire dov'è
L'uomo invisibile Mi aiuti Ok va bene
grazie
penso che riuscirà mai a trovarmi qua
vero Merlino una palla aiuto
no
c'è nessuno
[Musica]
si sta muovendo da sola
Questo è meglio che rimango qua in
silenzio
[Musica]
la parla
si sente
sta fluttuando
aiuto
[Musica]
Aiuto aiuto
per un pelo l'Uomo Invisibile mi stava
minacciando con una palla da ginnastica
forse cieco come ha fatto a non vedermi
cioè magari lui è al superpotere di
essere invisibile ma magari è cieco non
lo so comunque dobbiamo elaborare subito
un piano un'idea in mente prendiamo una
coperta e quando penso che lui si stia
avvicinando e li tiriamo sopra la
coperta Così vedremo Dov'è così potrò
legarlo e l'ho avrò catturato dentro
alla coperta Spero che funzioni dobbiamo
Innanzitutto andare a prendere la
coperta in camera io non con la coperta
dobbiamo tendergli una trappola sentite
queste salendo al piano di sopra sentite
i passi
è andato a nascondersi al piano di sopra
saliamo anche noi al piano di sopra e
gli facciamo una trappola li butterò la
coperta addosso e lo catturerò così
Vincerò la Challenge
Eccoci qua
non vedo nessuno andiamo
[Musica]
c'è nessuno
uomo invisibile
Ciao Merlino Merlino mi spaventato
Pensavo fossi lui invisibile
[Musica]
Mi raccomando se vedete qualcosa di
strano scrivetemelo
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa qua
l'altro si è Motta forse qua da qualche
parte
no maledizione non c'è niente
[Musica]
Ma tu
Merlino dov'è
c'è Dimmi dov'è Berlino dov'è
Gino dov'è qua
Guarda Merlino
dove sei Lo so che sei qua uomo
invisibile
Oh
no ho preso Merlino
no Merlino Scusa non era per te Tu devi
catturare un uomo invisibile Ok
sorpresa Ti ho preso
[Musica]
Merlino abbiamo preso
3 2 1
Scusa ma
no non c'è nessuno Questo cos'è deve
essere riuscito a scappare Merlino hai
capito Grazie per questi bacini di papà
forse abbiamo perso la Challenge
nuovamente vediamo cosa c'è scritto qua
Ok sì lo so che Sei impaziente aspetta
Merlino
Brava Hai vinto questa Challenge ma non
la battaglia non posso svelarti chi sono
Forse quando tornerò lo svelerò A presto
Hahaha visto Merlino Anche se non
abbiamo scoperto chi è l'Uomo Invisibile
Abbiamo comunque vinto la Challenge
abbiamo vinto questo nascondino
non sa proprio dove andare
[Musica]
ragazzi sono dentro la casa dobbiamo
seguire i simboli delle streghe per
trovare le streghe
Benvenuti su Anita Stories oggi nuova
Challenge
nascondino del tuo colore pauroso in
montagna perché oggi faremo
un'escursione in montagna e il percorso
delle streghe lasciate un bel mi piace
se volete altri video paurosi altri
nascondini Mettetevi comodi prendete i
Popcorn e iniziamo subito la Challenge
Ciao ragazzi Abbiamo viaggiato da Riva
del Garda in macchina e ora siamo a
Castelrotto in provincia di Bolzano
sull'alpe di siusis però che sto
pronunciando il tutto bene e stupendo
Qua ci siamo emozionati tantissimo nelle
strade perché saliva un sacco in alto
Comunque vi faccio un piccolo Room Tour
e poi vi faccio vedere il paesaggio
fuori siamo in un hotel che si chiama
Paradiso pur Living ed è stupendo siamo
un momento un po' un Room Tour Allora
qua c'è il
cabina armadio c'era una cosa
stranissima in cosa allora
il bagno è fighissimo È tutto di pietra
Wow
Guardate che bello il lavandino bianco e
nero
Praticamente ho notato una cosa
stranissima in bagno c'è Ci sono dei
pulsanti e penso che il bagno sia come
quello giapponese so che è un po' strano
farvi vedere un gabinetto in un hotel
però guardate questa cosa
Ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
vieni qua venite
allora qua c'è il letto il divanetto e
poi la parte più bella in assoluto è
questo balcone che è una vista
spettacolare venite
Guardate che bello
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ok tocca a me nascondermi tu Girati lì e
il colore che io scelgo è il blu Pronti
Via allora ho deciso di andare a
nascondermi laggiù guardate C'è una
lumaca gigante
questo hotel in cui stiamo è ricoperto
da lumache giganti blu
che ragazzi sono nascosta dietro alla
lumaca gigantesca blu e vediamo se
Vitale riuscirà a trovare
[Musica]
il tale e laggiù vedete non penso che mi
vedrà qua
Oh no forse mi è venuta non è possibile
che mi ha già trovato
definitivamente
Questa è blu
[Applauso]
e chi c'è qua
[Musica]
Ok Ora tocca a Vitale nasconderti che
colore scegli Fammi vedere scelgo Cerco
scelgo il tuo colore preferito il verde
ma come faccio a trovarti in mezzo al
verde quasi tutto verde Qua è tutto
bello e va bene Vai a nasconderti E io
aspetto qua e conterò fino a 60
[Musica]
trovato
l'albero però l'albero era troppo basso
appunto per me e ora proseguiamo Ragazzi
stiamo Percorrendo un percorso in
montagna e si chiama le sorgenti delle
streghe ed è molto inquietante Abbiamo
già trovato una cosa molto strana che
forse un tempo era una strega Guardate
Riuscite a vedere la faccia ma la vita
non gliene frega niente perché lui
vorrebbe mangiarsi i funghi Guardate
che belli un fungo giallo enorme
[Musica]
Wow
Che belli non li puoi mangiare sono
velenosi cioè potrebbero essere velenosi
e potresti anche morire Quindi no Uffa
Non è giusto però dai proseguiamo magari
troviamo altro da mangiare
fa un po' paura ma prova a toccarla
smettila
[Musica]
questo percorso si chiama le sorgenti
delle streghe perché alla fine si sono
le sorgenti sulfuree delle streghe e ma
ora tocca avvitare e nasconderti che
colori scegli scelgo il mio colore più
antipatico il marrone ma è tutto Marrone
Qua c'è marrone verde e va bene allora
vai a nasconderti e io dovrò cercarti ok
[Applauso]
camminare così tanto in sospeso
Ok nasconderci nella casetta Marrone
sull'altro corpo sugli alberi
[Applauso]
devo passare in modo che qui abbiamo la
casetta Marrone sull'albero
ci nascondiamo proprio qui nella casetta
sull'albero vediamo se riusciamo a
vedere Anita
facciamoci qui alla finestra
vediamo Dov'è dov'è
andata Non la vedo
ci siamo nascosti talmente tanto bene
che ci siamo persi
non so dove andare
è lì che scende
non sa proprio dove andare
[Musica]
Oh no
sto facendo proprio qui
Eccola oh no dove ci nascondiamo adesso
ci possiamo nasconderlo
[Musica]
qua ci siamo alla porta
ascoltiamoci dietro questa dietro il
tronco dell'albero qua
perfetto
c'è nessuno
Che strano Mi sembrava di aver visto
qualcuno qua
Dominick
tu mi hai fatto salire qua sopra
nonostante tu sappia che ho paura delle
altezze
mi sono nascosto Ora scendiamo subito Va
bene ragazzi che cos'è questo secondo
voi sembra qualcosa che le streghe hanno
lasciato per fare qualche stregoneria
rompendolo non so cosa serva però
[Musica]
Attraversiamo il Ponticello con la
cascata adesso
tocca a me nascondermi Io scelgo il
colore nero
girati a non guardare niente conta fino
a 60 andiamo a nasconderci dentro a
questa capanna che dentro è nera
[Musica]
ragazzi sono dentro la capanna ma è
tutto buio un po' di paura
[Musica]
Ok ragazzi sono al buio dentro la
capanna Spero che Vitale non mi troverà
qua ma fa molta paura qua dentro sono
uscita dalla capanna perché il tempo è
scaduto e vitale non mi ha trovato
hai perso
non mi hai trovato ero dentro alla
Capanna che era molto inquietante e
c'era tanto buio e spero che arrivassi
subito ma non mi hai trovato Ah perché
all'interno La Capanna era nera Sì
almeno ho vinto questo turno ragazzi ora
dobbiamo attraversare due Ponticelli
questo è basso non è un problema Ma
l'altro è un po' più alto
Castello
[Applauso]
come questo ponte
l'unica forza alternativa si sono rotti
vari punti che si sono rotti Elisa
guarda guarda
[Musica]
to
cos'era questo rumore Ecco il simbolo
delle streghe dobbiamo seguire i simboli
delle streghe per trovare le streghe
andiamo
Guarda questo ponte stregato
[Musica]
continuiamo la nostra avventura presso
questi percorsi creati dalle streghe
andiamo
ci sono delle frecce qua vuol dire che
siamo sulla strada giusta
una strega sicuramente è passata di qua
Guardate quell'albero
ragazzi siamo arrivati finalmente alla
sorgente di zolfo guardate
andiamo a vedere com'è e dobbiamo bere
l'acqua di zolfo e dicono che abbia
proprietà magiche ma solo questa è voi
non bevetela a casa È solo questa delle
streghe andiamo Speriamo di non
trasformarci in un fungo in un Folletto
o in uno di quei tronchi degli alberi
Ok ragazzi ci siamo Ecco qua L'acqua
sulfurea delle streghe beviamo la
vediamo com'è
che puzza
è freddissima
[Musica]
Ma ti stai trasformando
che puzza di uovo sodo
e trasformando in un rospo dopo l'acqua
delle streghe ha davvero un sapore
schifoso di uovo sodo Però dicono che
sia magica e che faccia molto bene alla
pelle comunque avremmo dovuto guardare
meglio il cartello perché guarda
c'è proprio l'immagine dell'uomo anche
se non capisco niente di quello che c'è
scritto Sean in alta Rom buste Man un
Dio Guardate
un'altra prova magica delle streghe
sono tre pietre enormi potrebbe caderti
Addosso
ho paura
Sì parecchio
Più che altro perché sono molto pesanti
hai per superare la prova delle streghe
ma non è che mi cadono sulla pancia però
non posso più mangiare
Hai paura che cadono addosso che mi sta
analizzando il cervello quindi le sta
muovendo la strega così cervello e
pancia sta memorizzando tutti i dati
potrò mangiare senza ingrassare
hai superato la l'ultima prova della 3
Adesso sì che posso farcela mangiare
tutto
sto aspettando che la strega vada via
quando smetti di muoversi la strega se
n'è andata ok sono libera
dall'incantesimo ora posso alzarmi
ce l'abbiamo fatta
non aprire c'è una strega in miniatura
là dentro sicuramente
no ho paura
Non lo so ma è meglio che ci
allontaniamo il più presto possibile
buttati i bambini cattivi no ecco
nuovamente il simbolo delle streghe sono
passate anche di qua
Ma dov'è finito Vitale
o non avranno preso le streghe
che cosa si faceva
nascondendo
quindi questo turno non vale Cos'è
questo è il trono dello Stregone Guarda
è quello
[Musica]
ragazzi la strega L'abbiamo trovata
Guardatelo giù
in mezzo agli alberi andiamo
la strega è stata pietrificata qua in
mezzo all'albero Wow
siamo riusciti a trovarla Speriamo che
non ci mandi qualche stregoneria qualche
maledizione Ciao strega Ciao raga Grazie
di questo percorso
[Musica]
ragazzi avete sentito scusate se sono al
buio e se parlo a bassa voce ma sono
nascosta dentro all'armadio vedete per
non farmi vedere da Granny questa nuova
Challenge dovrò giocare a nascondino con
i cattivi più cattivi di tutti e ci
saranno quattro turni Quindi quattro
round e io ho solo due vite quindi devo
cercare di non essere presa per più di
due volte altrimenti perderò la
Challenge Come avete visto la prima
Challenge e con granny Io sono nascosta
dentro questo armadio ma sto aspettando
che si distragga così posso andare
Magari nascondermi sopra al letto perché
ho paura che si metta a controllare
dentro gli armadi Mi raccomando lasciate
un bel mi piace se volete altre
Challenge con i cattivi se questo video
raggiunge i 30.000 mi piace ci sarà
un'altra Challenge con i cattivi Anzi
Consigliatemi voi che altro Challenge
volete vedere nel canale giù nei
commenti siete pronti prenditi i Popcorn
e iniziamo
la Challenge meglio chiudere
un po' aiuto
[Musica]
Ok forse sta uscendo dalla porta
è uscita
è andata di là ok Approfittiamone per
andare a nasconderci Ok ragazzi Eccomi
qua sono nel mio nascondiglio preferito
sopra al letto a castello e il mio
preferito perché ho un'ultima visuale da
qua e in genere non mi scoprono qua Ma
se avete visto le mie altre Challenge
sapete che a volte è andata a finire
male comunque
Eccola è lì alla porta
è andata verso l'armadio per fortuna
sono uscita da lì
si sta avvicinando qua
che mi nascondo
gli tiro qualche pupazzo così forse
andrà di là se sente un rumore sapete
che Greninja
tiriamo
quello sacrifico tiriamo questo
Ok è andata a rincorrerlo è arrivato
un pelo qua no no no non venire qua non
farle capire che sono qua Merlino ha
preso il pupazzo No lascialo lascialo Ok
bravo bravo Non prenderlo ok
se n'è andata forse è meglio che scendo
da qua Merlino fa silenzio mi raccomando
Ok ragazzi sono scesa dal letto ora vado
subito fuori dalla porta così posso
trovare un altro nascondiglio a Merlino
Merlino ha preso il pupazzo no là sono
Merlino
lascialo Bravo
Merlino anche se Merlino vorrebbe il
pupazzo però no Merlino no no no no no
no no no no
[Musica]
Ho già perso una vita il primo turno
l'ho già perso granny è bravissima a
giocare a nascondino anche se insomma le
sue intenzioni non penso che siano
proprio di giocare non so chi altro stia
venendo a cercarmi adesso tra i cattivi
quindi devo subito sbrigarmi a cercare
un nascondiglio Direi di uscire dallo
studio e andiamo in camera da letto
Non mi dire che c'è qualcuno qua
hai visto
Merlino di strano
ok Sono riuscita a nascondermi qua in
camera però te è andato di là e Merlino
mi sta guardando male Non so perché
che c'è Merlino che c'è
mi avrà visto
per fortuna
Merlino Aiuto non so se scappare
Chissà la porta
ma che sta facendo
e rotta chiese la porta e ora mi sta
fissando come se fossi un gelato al
caramello Ok forse è meglio scappare Mi
è venuta un'idea hot ha paura del caldo
perché è una sorta di mega gelato
gigante no Quindi se io esco fuori
Siccome c'è caldissimo in questi giorni
perché siamo in estate potrei portarlo
al sole e vedere se riesco a scioglierlo
così Vincerò il turno
dobbiamo scappare fuori sbrigati
[Musica]
Eccolo vieni pure Rod vieni pure qua al
sole e al caldo
vieni pure qua ma non sta facendo
effetto o sbaglio forse devo andare più
al sole Vieni proprio rincorri mi vieni
pure qua
sta scendendo
sta funzionando
si sta sciogliendo e ora è il momento
per me di scappare addio ciao ciao uomo
gelato
[Musica]
Sì abbiamo vinto abbiamo vinto questo
secondo turno Passiamo al terzo turno
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e penso che scenderò al piano di sotto
con Merlino se mi seguirà Merlino ma
stiamo molto attenti perché il prossimo
Cattivo che non so chi può essere si
potrebbe nascondere in ogni angolo
quindi Tenete gli occhi bene aperti
sembra che ci sia nessuno
andiamo verso la casetta uno dei nostri
nascondigli preferiti Dai andiamo
Merlino Andiamo nella casetta
Ok entriamo
Vieni fuori Merlino Vieni fuori nella
nostra casetta
che c'è
Merlino ha visto qualcosa forse era
dietro
Eccolo Merlino è tornato nella casetta
che stai facendo Merlino
se qualcuno la sotto non penso che un
cattivo possa stare là sotto
Chi è
nel senso che Granny 2 Il nonno lo
avete riconosciuto
non ho dimenticato di chiudere la porta
Merlino non andare lì eh Non andare da
Granny
che colori lo vedete
Merlino non leccare la porta
sto aspettando che io esca dalla casetta
Ma io non riuscirò No non userò mai da
qua
lui si sta avvicinando
Merlino Che ne pensi di rubargli la
mazza
io non lo vedo siamo riusciti a vincere
anche questo round visto che è scappato
andiamo
Lino vuoi rimanere nella casetta
Vabbè rimani pure lì io esco
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Granny 2 il nonno mi ha preso quindi ho
perso il terzo turno Questo è il quarto
e ultimo turno ma non ho più vite
disponibili Quindi se perdo questo tour
Avrò perso la Challenge quindi siamo
super attenti è arrivato Merlino ad
aiutarmi non so chi sia il prossimo
cattivo Oddio
piccolina vedete che sono spaventata un
sacco il stiamo a nasconderci subito e
non lo so andiamo qua Ok forse qua non
mi vede avete riconosciuto Chi è
se non l'avete vista bene
ora La vedrete perché sta entrando
Come hai fatto a vedermi Sì ciao Carlino
devi spostarti da qua altrimenti arriva
ma
è scomparsa Oh no è una sorta di
fantasma Merlino no Merlino non
rovesciate lo spazio
arrivo Merlino
lascia la spazzatura Ok lascia
aiuto
mi nascondo qua sotto al letto Ok
ragazzi sono sotto al letto
però che annabelle non mi vedrà qua
sotto a meno che non si avvicini Merlino
a sniffarmi e così scoprirà che sono qua
è andata via È andata via merlina forse
ce l'abbiamo fatta Ok possiamo
Merlino la sta distraendo Bravo Merlino
mandala via su mandala via
Mandalo via
signora stava andando via Bravo Merlino
caccia la via caccia la via per sempre
bravissima grazie a Merlino ho vinto
l'ultimo turno il quarto turno
[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi sono di nuovo dentro a un
armadio lo so perché questa è la seconda
parte del nascondino con i personaggi
cattivi ma questa volta sono ancora più
paurose ed inquietanti lo scorso video
Vi è piaciuto tantissimo se avete visto
ma mi sembra che ci sia una bambola che
mi sta cercando in questo momento spero
che non si accorga che sono qua dentro
all'armadio prima che mi trovi lasciate
un bel mi piace su questo video Provate
a lasciare un mi piace entro 5 secondi 5
4 3 2 1 tempo scaduto Siete riusciti a
lasciare mi piace entro 5 secondi se non
mi seguite ancora su Instagram andate a
seguirmi il nome Anita Stories Se volete
Seguitemi anche su Tik Tok alla fine del
video potrete scrivere nei commenti Qual
è il turno il round che vi ha fatto più
paura perché ci saranno quattro turni 4
round e io ho solamente due vite Quindi
se perdo più di due volte ho perso il
gioco e non potrò continuare e non ci
sarà una terza parte se invece vinco
potrà esserci la terza parte ti ha preso
i Popcorn iniziamo subito e vediamo come
scappare da questa bambola
[Musica]
è rimasta la mano incastrata
dove sta andando si è allontanato avete
visto
Mamma mia
via libera Possiamo uscire dall'armadio
Eccolo Merlino è sopra il letto Merlino
Mi raccomando fammi da guardia del corpo
anche oggi eh
Ok sono usciti
fino allontanati da lì Ciao ciao alla
finestra Spero che non mi abbia visto È
proprio lì Merlino hai visto non c'è più
ma si muove velocissimamente
Devi aiutarmi a trovarlo Ok Mi sa che
Merlino è troppo sonno oggi per aiutarmi
in questa Challenge
ha iniziato a sniffare qualcosa forse ha
visto qualcosa non Merlino impossibile
che sia sotto il letto c'è troppo poco
spazio sotto al letto per Chucky
Vabbè siccome non lo vedo da nessuna
parte direi che provo a scappare
velocissimamente fuori dalla porta se
riesco a scappare avrò vinto altrimenti
no
dai Merlino andiamo proviamo a scappare
su E vabbè Merlino vuole rimanere qui a
dormire Beh noi scappiamo
Avete visto ciò che era lì ho
dimenticato un bambino dentro Merlino
sbrigati sbrigati è proprio lì sbrigati
Merlino Merlino Oh no Merlino è andato
da Chucky
lascialo lascialo pericoloso vieni
[Musica]
Ragazzi abbiamo vinto il primo turno non
so come siamo riusciti a scappare da
Chucky Forse perché Merlino li ha
beccato la faccia e già chi è rimasto
tipo piede efficace Comunque ora siamo
al secondo round secondo turno non so
ancora chi sia il cattivo del secondo
turno ho paura che spunterò fuori
all'improvviso come tutti gli altri
Quindi teniamo gli occhi bene aperti
iniziamo a cercare un nascondiglio
perché il cattivo potrebbe comparire da
un momento all'altro
avete capito che il cattivo
è bendy forse devo evitare quella
direzione e andare qua proviamo andare
qua Tu che dici Merlino da che parte
Andiamo a destra o a sinistra
era il cartone vi ricordate nella
Challenge Trova gli ingredienti Slime
nascosti da bendy lui usa il cartone di
se stesso per distrarmi
Quindi lui potrebbe essere qua o qua
dove Merlino Cerca cerca Merlino
e dietro la porta Ok allora meglio
cambiare direzione
Beh io me ne torno qua in studio così
non potrai mai prendermi bendy Ciao ciao
chi è
Merlino Sei stato tu a bussare
No non è possibile che sei stato tu tu
non hai
le mani alle zampe
Merlino Dimmi tu da che parte devo
andare ok
sei meglio se vuole dalla parte opposta
Andiamo di qua da che parte andiamo
sopra alle scale
Cosa vorrà dire Devo andare via devo
andare sopra alle scale sopra le scale
potrebbe esserci Benji ma anche a destra
potrebbe esserci bendy non mi fido
secondo me è un tranello quello del
cartonato quindi provo a salire sopra le
scale Ok ragazzi saliamo le scale
Speriamo che sia la scelta
giusta qua Casomai arrivi bene
piano piano
non mi sembra che ci sia nessuno
Che cos'è questo rumore
Merlino Grazie per avermi svegliato ma
abbiamo perso il secondo round quindi ho
già perso una vita mi rimane solamente
una vita Questo è il terzo è penultimo
round chi sarà il cattivo Non lo so ma è
meglio se cerchiamo subito un
nascondiglio andare verso bendy non è
stata una buona idea quindi questa volta
voglio nascondermi e rimanere immobile
così chiunque sia il cattivo non mi
troverà Spero siamo nuovamente in studio
e se vi ricordate nell'altro episodio
quando mi sono nascosta sopra al letto a
castello nel letto di sopra sono
riuscita a vedere granny che entrava e
tirarle un pupazzo ed è andata
abbastanza bene devo dire tranne che poi
era nascosto nell'armadio ma provo anche
questa volta a stare sopra il letto così
il cattivo probabilmente non mi vede
era qualcosa di bianco
non mi viene in mente nessuno tutto
bianco forse è un fantasma dobbiamo
prendere qualcosa per difendersi dal
fantasma prima di salire sopra al letto
devo trovare un lenzuolo o qualcosa del
genere ti sono in bagno ho preso un
asciugamano Perché i lenzuoli sono in
camera da letto e ho paura che il
fantasma sia in camera da letto ora
scappiamo subito bene ragazzi sono nel
mio nascondiglio preferito sopra il
letto con tutti i pupazzi e ho qua
l'asciugamano in caso di difesa dal
fantasma credo che sia un fantasma
[Musica]
Prova a tirargli l'asciugamano in testa
Ora lo apro Spero che funzioni
[Musica]
Speriamo ho solo una possibilità se non
riesco a beccarlo si accorgerà di me
Sì ce l'ho fatta
Ma perché è rimasto immobile che succede
Che succede non si muove più
è scomparso Guardate è rimasto solo
l'asciugamano per terra abbiamo vinto
questo turno questo round per fortuna
perché mi rimaneva solo una vita e ora
passiamo al quarto turno e vediamo chi è
il cattivo finale
[Musica]
per l'ultimo turno ho deciso di scendere
al piano di sotto andiamo assieme e
scopriamo Chi è l'ultimo cattivo
Eccoci qua al piano di sotto
ancora non è comparso nessuno vado a
nascondermi dietro e si fa
[Musica]
R
che mi sono nascosta qua dietro la porta
Merlino
[Musica]
ha avuto un'idea sul tavolo ci sono dei
Fiori io proverò a lanciare i fiori in
un'altra direzione così lui forse
Seguirà il rumore perché vi ricordate
che bisogna distrarlo e lanciare le cose
lui Senti rumori va da un'altra parte e
quando lui sarà distratto proverò a
scappare al piano di sopra Speriamo di
riuscirci
per
esempio
Merlino vieni qua spero che Merlino non
mangi i fiori
llino
distratto Ok Scappiamo
presto scappiamo di sopra ragazzi ce
l'abbiamo fatta ci è mancato un pelo con
Hello neighbor però ce l'abbiamo fatta
che c'è Merlino
cosa hai visto
[Musica]
Che cos'è quello
il coniglio
[Musica]
il coniglio ma non è Pasqua siamo a
settembre Oh no deve essere un altro
episodio di nascondino con i pazzi che
entrano a casa di Anita Ebbene sì nuovo
episodio Tranne i cattivi questa volta
del primo lo abbiamo già visto il
coniglio pazzo di Pasqua Ve lo ricordate
è molto cattivo Il problema è che
Merlino è uscito fuori devo
assolutamente andare a recuperarlo ma
non farmi prendere dal coniglio mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
entro questa volta 4 secondi 4 3 2 1
tempo scaduto ci siete riusciti ora
Mettetevi comodi e prendete i Popcorn e
speriamo di vincere questa Challenge
nascondino assieme Andiamo a recuperare
Merlino fuori ragazzi Mi è venuta
un'idea geniale per riuscire a non farmi
trovare dal coniglio o per distrarlo vi
ricordate nella Challenge in cui ho
sconfitto il coniglio come lo sconfitto
se ve lo ricordate scrivetelo qua sotto
nei commenti sconfitto Anita il coniglio
cattivo nella Challenge di Pasqua e se
non l'avete vista poi andate a vederla
dopo questo video comunque
Userò la stessa arma
Come arrivo
ma lo dicono dal coniglio invece sta
inseguendo le lucertole Ma che fai
[Musica]
ah ah aiuto
[Applauso]
Prendi questa
[Musica]
lascia la carota Berlino e per il
coniglio non è per te oh no
Merlino lascia la subito lasciala
il solito ladro lascia la Merlino lascia
subito la carota non è per te per il
coniglio
lasciala come sempre Berlino il solito
ladro vi ricordate quella volta che
tiravo le banane al gorilla ma lui le ha
rubate se le ha mangiate Ma no il
coniglio sarà secondo Berlino perché è
una carota
lascialo Merlino Ma dov'è finita e
laggiù
ù mescola
lui ne sta rosicchiando un pezzo presto
tiriamola il coniglio
aiuto che paura prendila
Merlino vieni qua non è per te
Prendi questa
devo approfittare della distrazione
Merlino ha rubato la carota al coniglio
ora il coniglio sta seguendo Merlino non
posso stare a salvarlo ogni volta devo
ritornare dentro e scappare così potrò
vincere il round
ragazzi siamo riusciti a vincere il
primo round grazie a Merlino che ha
distratto il coniglio mangiando tutte le
carote Lì c'è il solito ladro passiamo
ora al secondo round e vediamo chi ci
aspetta
[Musica]
Ok ragazzi secondo round non ho ancora
visto chi è il cattivo del secondo round
però ho deciso di scendere al piano di
sotto perché ci sono più nascondigli
interessanti In più ho deciso di
prendere questo lenzuolo vi ricordate In
quale video c'è stato questo lenzuolo a
cui ho fatto i buchi per travestirmi da
fantasma e poi per spaventare Vitale
Merlino vediamo chi si ricorda In quale
video è successo scrivetelo nei commenti
comunque userò questo lenzuolo stile
fantasma per nascondermi meglio non so
chi sarà il cattivo Spero che sia un
cattivo che ci caschi Ok andiamo ora al
piano di sotto e scopriamolo assieme
ragazzi Qua il piano di sotto è molto
più buio quindi farà un pochino più di
paura
[Musica]
c'è nessuno
strano sembra proprio che non ci sia
nessuno qua bene meglio così magari il
cattivo è al piano di sopra oppure è
fuori e sarai ancora più difficile per
lui trovarmi
o no Avete sentito
perché
mi sta cercando nel tavolo
bello per poco non mi trovavo là dietro
alla porta meglio che metto subito
questo mensola addosso così magari mi
scambia per il muro magari riesco a
mimetizzarmi e non mi troverà Piggy
Ok la prova mimetizzarmi
[Musica]
Ok ragazzi siamo al terzo
round siamo nella cameretta
forse è meglio che decido un
nascondiglio prima entri il prossimo
cattivo ma ora non vedo nessuno meglio
così almeno un po' di tempo per
nascondermi la porta
è aperta
l'ho impostato sul letto
vi ricordate il lupo ha un sonno molto
profondo Quindi penso che posso parlare
normalmente e nascondo Forse si sta
svegliando Dov'è vado sotto al letto
andiamo
Ok ragazzi sono nascosta sotto al letto
spero che non mi trovi quaggiù
è ancora lì che dorme ma quanto tempo
dovrò stare qua sotto prima o poi si
sveglierà e mi cercheranno
piedi pelosi
mi sta cercando
paura
è proprio un lupo rabbioso
con questa regola
non guardare qua non
[Musica]
guardare
ragazzi Il lupo è uscito fuori devo
spiegarmi e cercare di chiuderlo fuori a
chiave
[Musica]
Ok chiusa a chiave non dovrebbe riuscire
ad aprire la porta
Ah forse non riesci neanche ad aprire le
maniglie perché ha le zampe
Ragazzi abbiamo vinto il terzo round
quindi ho vinto due partite Ne ho perso
una sono in vantaggio
[Musica]
Ah che bellissima giornata per un
campeggio fuori c'è caldo ma non troppo
fa per fare buio e soprattutto non c'è
nessun pazzo che viene disturbarmi
[Musica]
Oh no
Merlino mi sono spaventata avvisami
quando entri nella tenda busta almeno no
Mi raccomando se non mi seguite ancora
su Instagram andate a seguirmi su
Instagram e se volete andate a seguirmi
anche su Tik Tok e Provate a lasciare un
mi piace a questo video in 5 secondi 5 4
3 2 1 tempo scaduto ci siete riusciti
prendete i Popcorn e iniziamo pure
questo campeggio al buio di notte
assieme
ci sono dei rumori strani fuori
Ah no
Questo è un Merlino che sgranocchia un
pezzo di albero controlliamo fuori dalla
finestra
[Musica]
ma hanno perso un giorno sono proprio di
5 giorni come nel videogioco di granny
quindi dobbiamo sbrigarci perché
preferirei sconfiggere granny alla luce
che al buio via libera usciamo e
cerchiamo gli oggetti che possono
servirci per sconfiggere granny o per
scappare dentro casa non è che mi
aiuteresti Mi aiuti a trovare gli
oggetti o sei troppo Sì ma Merlino Ma
perché stai andando via dentro qui
indaffarato a mangiare pezzo di ramo
Merlino c'è qualcosa qua sopra
Uh Che cos'è questo no Dove scappi
Merlino
[Musica]
dammelo Berlino lasciala lascialo
lascialo
ho dovuto rincorrere Merlino per tutto
il giardino perché non voleva lasciare
il Nerf voleva sgranocchiare e
distruggerlo con i suoi denti come ogni
cosa Sono molto contenta perché adesso
un qualcosa per difendermi da granny ora
continuiamo a esplorare a cercare altri
oggetti
[Applauso]
che ci arrivo lì è lì ma non può essere
lì hanno solo una lucertola
[Applauso]
se mi ha visto
Che bello funziona
non funziona
Sì ha funzionato Ho sconfitto granny ce
l'ho fatta granny sconfitta
[Musica]
Berlino Purtroppo ho perso un'altra vita
Pensavo che il Nerf avesse sconfitto
Granny in realtà la rallenta e basta
quindi devo stare molto attenta e
utilizzarlo solo per rallentarla
mi sembra di vedere qualcosa laggiù
qualcosa di rosso
[Applauso]
è una cassetta
hai visto Merlino una cassetta Rossa
a cosa servirà
[Applauso]
Beccati questo
Merlino No no Lascialo Lascia lascia
morire bravissimo Che cosa vuol dire no
ma ora dobbiamo scappare si riempi
[Applauso]
devo chiudere la porta
Merlino spostatevi
non è proprio una porta è tipo un telo
Spero che si allontana al più presto nel
frattempo devo capire cosa significa
questo disegno è tipo un gatto fatto di
triangoli che cosa Può voler dire
Sicuramente è un indizio per riuscire a
tornare dentro casa Mi è venuta un'idea
perché non provo a entrare dentro casa
anche senza risolvere Gli enigmi ed
indovinelli magari riesco a entrare lo
stesso Non ho bisogno di risolvere tutti
gli indovinelli grandi ci rimarrebbe
malissimo Ok proviamo a entrare Merlino
che stai facendo
merlina stava sgranocchiando il Nerf
ovviamente
Smettila non è che un tuo gioco Merlino
Lo so che i colori sembrano quelli dei
tuoi giochini Non è il tuo giochino
siamo fuori dalla tenda
Oh si sono accese le luci fuori meno
male almeno non sarà buio pesto andiamo
verso la porta di casa e speriamo che
sia aperta
Ok magari è aperta vediamo
questa è aperta
No
è chiusa
mi nascondo qua
però
[Musica]
questa Challenge si sta rivelando molto
più difficile del normale è sempre un
po' difficile con granny Ma è ancora più
difficile in campeggio
È lì dietro la tenda venitevo per forza
Risolvere questo indovinello voi
riuscite a capire cosa Può voler dire
nel frattempo che i criniera quella
parte io provo andare a vedere che cos'è
la cassetta Rossa Magari c'è qualche
indizio lì
sarebbe
molto attenti
Eccola qua magari la chiave qua dentro
vediamo C'è un lucchetto ma non è un
lucchetto con una chiave e un lucchetto
con i numeri hai visto Merlino no è
inutile che lo lecchi non si apre Solo
le orecchie
Grazie dell'aiuto merlina No ma non
funziona così quindi vuol dire che devo
trovare la giusta combinazione provo a
mettere un numero a caso
non succede niente Ho capito quindi
quell'immagine nasconde in realtà il
numero della combinazione del lucchetto
per aprire questa cassetta devo riuscire
a capire subito Qual è il numero sono
qua con il mio indovinello Sto cercando
di capire quale potrebbe essere il
numero nascosto qui ma non mi viene in
mente niente
è meglio chiudere la testa
così siamo più al sicuro Comunque
l'unico numero che potrebbe essere
associato a granny è il 1900 la sua data
di nascita
Spero che non si arrabbi
forse mi ha sentito
nogres Intendevo dire che sei
giovanissima sei nata nel 2010
Si è notato che questo gatto è formato
solamente da triangoli forse devo
contare i triangoli e quello sarà il
numero del lucchetto un triangolo e la
testa due sono le orecchie quindi uno
due tre qua negli occhi a due triangoli
ciascuno Quindi 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 non sono sicura se contare
anche questi due piccoli triangolini
Spero di sì penso che il numero sia 16
ora non ci resta che andare e provare
il tempo
qualcuno qua
non vedo nessuno
[Applauso]
Oh no credimi che ti sta avvicinando
Allora 0 ci sono tre cifre Quindi
immagino che la prima sia lo zero zero
uno uno
dove sei doversi e così Speriamo che
funzioni
Anzi ha funzionato
Ecco la chiave Scappiamo
sono arrivato
Non riesco ad aprire non funziona
Non ci posso credere ragazzi sono
riuscita a rientrare in casa per un pelo
grani era proprio dietro alla porta
[Musica]
vediamo vediamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Qualcuno ha bussato alla porta che c'è
Merlino
C'è qualcuno
non c'è nessuno
strappi Ciao Anita
Ti ricordi di me ti va di giocare
è meglio se inizi a nascondersi tanto ti
troverò
devo subito avvisare Vitale che slappi è
tornato era in studio lo avete visto ha
detto Tanto non riuscirai a nasconderti
Quindi è meglio se troviamo subito un
nascondino andiamo qua dietro Ok ragazzi
sono nascosta in un angolino dietro la
cassettiera ovviamente voi fate il tipo
per me e lasciate un bel mi piace sotto
questo video Se volete vedere altri
video nascondino o altri video paurosi
Mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
Mettetevi comodi prendete i Popcorn e
iniziamo subito la Challenge nascondino
pauroso
[Musica]
non vedo niente
e nessuno dobbiamo ricordare
che cosa ci fai lì sto nascondendo
nascondendo non c'è tempo di spiegarti
adesso sbrigati vai in studio
dobbiamo andare in studio
Dov'è Merlino lo hai visto era sul letto
Merlino vieni qua Bravo Merlino senti Lo
so che ti sembrerà super strano ma è
tornato slappy e come ha fatto a tornare
Beh ti ricordi che l'ultima volta non
era del tutto scomparso forse è colpa
del bambolaio non lo so comunque era
proprio lì era lì sopra il tavolo guarda
è proprio qui era seduto qua e ha fatto
insomma la sua solita voce brutta e
fastidiosa dobbiamo sbarazzarcene questa
volta una volta per tutte Quindi
dobbiamo escogitare un piano prima che
torni anche potrebbe essere qua fuori
dalla porta che ci ascolta Fammi
controllare ah
sei scemo Hahaha
Ma mi sembra che non stai prendendo
questa cosa molto sul serio per
spaventarti un attimino
Digli tu qualcosa dove dobbiamo
nasconderci adesso Merlino di andare
fuori Merlino Mi raccomando proteggici
anche oggi tu che sei la nostra guardia
del corpo Il nostro cane guardia del
corpo Grazie per questi bacini comunque
capisci che non c'è tempo flappy qua in
casa da qualche parte e noi dobbiamo
trovare un nascondiglio Anzi prima
dobbiamo trovare un piano per
liberarsene avevi in mente qualcosa per
liberarci di slappy e non lo so proviamo
ad invitarlo a cena Gli diamo gli devo
da mangiare a qualcuno non mangia io
penso che dobbiamo innanzitutto prendere
qualcosa per difenderci quindi scegliamo
un'arma per difenderci Ok ok È un'ottima
idea Magari tu potresti prendere la
macchina magari una pila perché a lui da
fastidio la luce forte ok Ottima idea sì
procediamo così allora
italiano una pila Ma siccome gli dà
fastidio la luce potrebbe accecarlo per
qualche secondo così Avrei il tempo di
scappare Però se non elaboriamo un piano
più concreto non riusciremo mai a
sbarazzarci di slappy vero Merlino Ti
ricordi la scatola che non possiamo
aprire in cui abbiamo messo anche la
maschera che non dovevamo mai indossare
la maschera maledetta Eh sì però non è
una buona idea Secondo me è pericoloso
almeno sappiamo
che poi si mette la maschera diventa
doppiamente potente sarebbe impossibile
da sconfiggere in quel caso ma lo sai
che le cose che mettiamo là dentro
scompaiono attiriamolo al piano di sopra
vicino alla scatola e una volta che si
avvicina lì tu gli tirerai un colpo di
Mazza e lo butteremo Dentro alla scatola
Sì magari prima lo accechi e poi con la
mazza lo butto dentro vediamo di
riuscirci sai che lui è molto furbo però
è anche molto lento a spostarsi quindi
forse possiamo riuscire dobbiamo stare
arrivando da un momento all'altro hai
Merlino sarà il nostro asso nella manica
perché sarà la nostra guardia del corpo
e ci avvertirà se sta arrivando qualcuno
con il suo naso dal fiuto infallibile
alle sue orecchie dall'udito infallibile
senza Berlino non so dove saremmo adesso
ora dobbiamo capire dove nasconderci
Merlino Mi sa che ci sta già
consigliando qualcosa Guarda
sotto al letto Ok allora io mi nascondo
dove mi sta consigliando Merlino cioè
sotto al letto ok Invece tu puoi uscire
fuori dalla porta e fare la guardia alla
porta vado subito allora se lui si
avvicina dobbiamo tirarlo al piano di
sopra Mi raccomando che io mi nascondo
sotto al letto Mi raccomando fai bene la
guardia alla porta e Avvisami se arriva
qualcuno Certo certo Merlino vieni con
me vieni vieni Merlino Merlino non ci
stiamo in tutte e due
dai piedi Merlino
tranquillo Questo è solo il mio
nascondiglio
Bravo Vieni con me noi siamo qui ok a
fare di guardia alla porta Ok bravissimi
a prenderlo Ok speriamo che non succeda
niente a Vitale
è strano Sento la sua presenza ma non la
vedo Chissà dove sei La storia
[Musica]
questo rumore Sbaglio o proveniva
proprio da qua sotto Esso controlliamo
vediamo un po'
li farò prendere un bello spavento
Beccati questo slappy
ragazzi ci siamo riusciti ho cercato
slappy
Ciao Merli Ma tu non ti sei accorto di
niente perché non mi hai protetto dalla
bambola parlante non mi dire che stavi
dormendo
Ah questo è l'ora del tuo riposino
ragazzi slappy non c'è più Devo averlo
accecato veramente
ha funzionato meglio che tengo la pila
sempre con me Ma si può sapere dov'eri
finito
dalle scale
sono andato a vedere che risposte che
cosa stesse facendo veramente slappy era
qui anzi mi ha anche trovato ma per
fortuna avevo la pila e l'ho accecato e
una volta che li ho puntato la pila
addosso e è rimasto un po' stranito e
ora è scomparsa Brava Sei riuscito
benissimo a difenderti da sola senza il
mio aiuto eh Eh sì ma tu dovevi fare la
guardia alla porta dove sei sparito
Prima pensavo di andare a prendere
slappy appunto perché avevo sentito il
rumore sotto Invece lui era venuto qui
mi ha ingannato e alla fine che rumore
era Non lo so Forse è stato lui stesso a
fare un rumore per ingannarmi non c'era
niente Beh stiamo molto attenti adesso
perché penso che si sia un po'
arrabbiato del fatto che l'ho accecato
Uh è meglio che iniziamo subito ad
attuare il piano finale e cioè saliamo
al piano di sopra e prepariamo la sua
trappola per rinchiuderlo Dentro alla
scatola andiamo Cioè è piena di sopra
questa è l'arma segreta il teatrino
Infatti lui è un burattino e quindi è
molto attirato dai teatrini e se vedete
i teatrini compare perché è già successo
una volta vi ricordate quindi noi
metteremo il teatrino qua faremo in modo
che lui compaia e poi Vitale rimarrà
pronto a colpirlo e poi io sarò nascosta
sotto al letto con la pizza salta il
tavolo con la fine proprio qua sotto
così Mi terrò pronta nel caso che non
funzioni il piano proverò ad accecarlo e
se funziona slappi cadrà nella scatola
una volta che è caduto Io sarò qua a
richiudere la scatola per sempre così
potrà sparire per sempre Ecco la scatola
Eccola è pronta Mi raccomando Stai molto
attento
dove la
posizioneala qui Speriamo che il nostro
pianto
Ok Sembra tutto ok per il momento
[Musica]
Mi raccomando se arriva troppi Devi
lasciarlo passare Ok deve venire qua e
cadere nella nostra trappola Ok ora che
è tutto pronto Non ci resta che
nasconderci e aspettare che arrivi
slappy Speriamo che arrivi ma ci caschi
[Musica]
andiamo
e bello
metterò in atto un bello spettacolo per
la vita
[Applauso]
facile
Allora iniziamo il gatto
spettacolo
all'improvviso per spaventarli quindi mi
metterò ad aspettare il frutto qui
davanti a questo termine
[Musica]
dove sono sopra
il paziente
[Musica]
Chiudi chiudi Aspetta vai cosa aiutarti
ce l'abbiamo fatta Abbiamo sconfitto il
pranzo
no
Merlino non è dentro il cestino
[Musica]
Benvenuti su Anita Stories Io sono Anita
lui è Merlino E io continuo Ciao oggi
nuova Challenge giochiamo a nascondino
Però giochiamo a nascondino con Merlino
Merlino cosa stai facendo ha già
iniziato a giocare Merlino
ovviamente Merlino dovrà trovarmi tale
conterrà fino a 20 e io dovrò andare a
nascondermi e Merlino riesce a trovarmi
per più volte vince Merlino Se invece io
riesco a non farmi trovare per più volte
vinco io mi raccomando lasciate un bel
mi piace questo video Se volete vedere
altre Challenge con Merlino il nostro
cagnolino
Io c'ho sonno prendete il pop corn e
mettetevi comodi e iniziamo subito la
Challenge Ok ora Vitale conterà fino a
20 e io dovrò nascondermi
[Musica]
l'armadio Secondo voi Merlino riuscirà a
trovarmi dentro l'armadio
bene altrimenti
mi vede anche se Merlino sicuramente
tutto e quali sono
usciti
è andato da un'altra parte non mi ha
visto
Qui non c'è Padre Pio
però
ho trovato che bravo Merlino
bravo
Ma ti vuoi nascondere anche tu dentro
l'armadio
da Merlino non riesco uscire togli
questo sederino Allora siamo 1-0 ha
vinto Merlino il primo round Ora secondo
round Vitale conta e vado a nascondere
vai vai vai vai vai vai
ok
Sono
sotto le scale non so se riuscirò a
trovarmi qua spero di no 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 togliamo le dita eh
Merlino siamo pronti andiamo subito a
cercare il padroncino
No più interessato allego che a cercare
Anita pronti andiamo
a cercarlo Merlino devo cercarla
dove
sta andando dove
Dove hai sentito Hai sentito
Secondo me Merlino è molto più
interessato a sgranocchiare il suo LEGO
che a trovare Anita
[Applauso]
torno questa volta cercherò di farlo un
po' più difficile Ok Questa volta loro
partiranno dalla camera da letto così è
un po' più di spazio Merlino vieni
il tuo giochino quello che resta del tuo
giochino in realtà perché te lo sei
sgranocchiato tutto lo so lo so il tuo
sigirino
Ah dobbiamo iniziare a raccontare mi ero
dimenticato Uno due tre Merlino 4 5 6 13
14 15 16 17 18
ce l'abbiamo fatta andiamo Merlino
andiamo a cercare padroncina andiamo a
cercare patrocinio dai
cerca di qua dov'è ma Berlino vuole
salire sopra perché qui ci sono i
giochini
è andata questa volta
Cerca Merlino Cerca
nell'armadio di nuovo ma no non credo
Cerca
davvero
no Merlino non si muove quindi mi sta
facendo capire che mi sto muovendo nella
direzione sbagliata ti fermi lì
Stiamo cercando
Merlino
Dov'è finita davvero
Merlino sei troppo bravo in questo gioco
Come faccio a nascondere perché io sono
Luca infallibile però ci ha messo un po'
a trovarmi Eh Stavo andando in giro per
le stanze ma anche loro
è Merlino Ma insomma Dove stai andando
quarto turno per questa volta si
nasconde
si nasconderà a Vitale Vediamo se
Merlino lo trova più velocemente o meno
velocemente magari non lo trovo proprio
Vediamo la differenza Secondo me andrà a
cercare il suo giochino Invece di
cercare a me vediamo perché
sono innamoratissimo di Vitale dove
dovete saperlo Pronti 1 2 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19
[Musica]
Berlino sta già ascoltando si sta
concentrando con le sue orecchiette
Vediamo quanto è bravo a trovarlo in
quanto tempo lo trova
Cerca un palloncino
Dov'è il palloncino
quando
Dov'è dice che qua dietro
[Musica]
cercando
no Merlino non mi sembra che sia qua
Dov'è patroncino Merlino
[Musica]
Mi sa che Merlino questa volta
è un po' confuso non è sicuro Cerco
Cerca cerca Dov'è dov'è subito subito
[Musica]
proviamo a fare il silenzio Magari
riusciamo a sentire qualche suono fatto
da padroncino
io non sento niente
Merlino tu con il tuo fiuto infallibile
dovresti sentire l'odore di padroncino
dov'è
No non può essere dentro il cestino
non ci entra là dentro
No Merlino non è dentro al cestino
no Merlino stai cercando nel posto
sbagliato
Merlino
ti assicuro che non è lì Guarda ti
faccio vedere Ecco vedi non c'è
padroncino qua dentro non mi credi
ancora
Questa era quel rumore
Merlino ha sentito un rumore
lo fai perlina Mi sa che Merlino
pensa che sia sotto il tavolo
sta sniffando
però non capisce dove
forse Berlino perderà questo turno
Perché non è riuscito a trovarlo Ok
allora contiamo fino a 20 e se Berlino
non riesce a trovarlo Avrà vinto Vitale
[Musica]
10 12 10 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
[Applauso]
Allora siamo tre a uno uno è un punto è
per Vitale e tre per Merlino questo ora
è l'ultimo turno Io mi dovrò nascondere
dovrò cercare di farlo il più difficile
possibile e vediamo chi vince Vediamo se
Berlino riesce a trovarmi anche questa
volta
pronti Ok prende la camera Vitale
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 siamo pronti 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20 cominciamo cominciamo
cominciamo
ad uscire dai cerca
Cerca Dov'è dov'è
di qua è andata
andiamo
Merlino Non ti far distrarre dei giochi
eh Merlino
[Musica]
Cerca
cerca Merlino
Merlino dove
qualcuno si è dimenticato delle ciabatte
qui vicino
Stasera stai cercando nelle piante
che cosa stai facendo Ti sei incastrato
nel treppiedi No non è qua dentro Non
puoi essere qua dentro padroncina
Allora Togliamo questo treppiedi Secondo
me ti fai male
[Musica]
dove Cerca cerca
Merlino Cerca
Guarda Merlino Guarda No non è neanche
nelle piante No non ti mangiare le
piante Tra l'altro queste secca
no fermo
Cerca Merlino Cerca
non ce la posso dire
mi sa che qualcuno sta vincendo di nuovo
qua ci sono troppi indizi le ciabatte
qui per terra le porte che si aprono
Merlino
sei vicino sei vicinissimo Merlino
sei troppo vicino Berlino
Che bravo ha trovato di nuovo
Sei bravissimo Merlino
troppo bravo Sei troppo bravo in questo
gioco Merlino è bravissimo Quanti punti
siamo quindi
stiamo 410
questa Challenge Non ho visto neanche
una volta pensavo che qua sarebbe stato
super complicato trovarmi che sono in
alto e invece Merlino è un cane è
bravissimo ed è riuscito a trovarti Eh
mi ha fiutato subito
Ciao ciao
Sto iniziando a mettere le decorazioni
per Halloween
un po' paurosa con un castello
pipistrelli
poi c'è questo che in teoria non c'entra
niente con Halloween candelabro della
Bella e la Bestia facciamo finta di
niente Poi abbiamo queste questi
Calderoni in cui in effetti si potrebbe
mischiare qualche Slime due calderoncini
che Merlino Prima stava cercando di
mangiare questa pianta bellissima che fa
i fiori
arancioni con il gatto Wow il gatto nero
quindi questa è la mia piantina di
Halloween in effetti non ho tantissime
decorazioni di Halloween già finite Ah
questo cerchietto e poi è un cerchietto
anche per te Secondo me ti sta benissimo
Merlino Secondo te come Chissà questo di
Halloween è una padroncino
[Musica]
tu vuoi per Merlino ho trovato il
costume di Halloween per Merlino lo
proviamo Merlino scheletrino diventa
proviamolo subito Eccolo qua oh sempre
un
cane ma te lo
da subito Wow
dormire sul sonno e Merlino ha un po' di
sonno Volevo solo sgrano perché è
cambiato l'orario e lui è abituato a
dormire prima no dopo Comunque è un po'
confuso e quindi pensa che questo sia il
suo momento per dormire se vuoi dormi
Merlino è tranquillo
Siete contenti che fra pochissimo è
Halloween e la mia festa preferita in
assoluto ormai sapete benissimo che mi
piacciono tantissimo le cose paurose e
se Seguite il mio canale Sicuramente
piacciono anche a voi le cose paurose ma
Halloween è una festa super fantastica
Secondo me e a voi piace Halloween
[Musica]
Hai sentito Merlino cos'era
C'è qualcuno alla porta
andiamo a vedere
chi è
nessuno
non c'è nessuno
solo immaginati stai La notte di
Halloween Halloween sembra che tutto sia
così pauroso vero Merlino altrimenti
Merlino se ne sarebbe subito accorto
vero
[Applauso]
hanno portato di nuovo
di Merlino andiamo a controllare chi è
Secondo te
una zucca una zucca
Hai per caso ho ordinato una zucca io no
forse l'ha ordinata Merlino allora
Merlino
hai comprato tu questa zucca Forse ce
l'ha inviata qualcuno come regalo Beh
comunque è un'ottima decorazione per
Halloween mi mancava proprio così allora
Dove la mettiamo qui
Wow È bellissima
Ci sta benissimo qua Beh grazie a
chiunque la abbia inviato Merlino
e ora possiamo chiudere la porta e
continuare a organizzare il tutto per
Halloween
Hai sentito hanno buttato nuovamente e
chi sarà questa volta ci hanno inviato
un nuovo regalo
che c'è Merlino abbiamo la zucca Ci
avranno dato anche il riso così facciamo
un risotto alla zucca Pensi sempre a
mangiare sì certo
Queste sono uguali le zucche gemelle Eh
vabbè mettiamole tutte qua a fianco e
queste sono un pochino più cattive deve
esserci qualcosa un biglietto che ci
dice chi ce le ha mandate Non ti sembra
strano Molto strano soprattutto Tre
Zucche Guarda c'è qualcosa qua dentro
Non lo so forse un biglietto forse c'è
scritto che ce le ha mandate
devo riuscire a toglierlo senza rompere
la zucca guarda sono riuscita a
toglierlo
vediamo cosa c'è scritto
[Musica]
questa casa appartiene ora a noi
zuccheri andatevene via o verrete
decorati
svuotati e Messi come soprammobili come
fate voi umani con noi zuccheri firmato
Jack o' Lantern il re delle zucche è uno
scherzo
ma vuole da noi è stato lui a inviarci
le zucche Tu cosa ne pensi Merlino non
capisco se è uno scherzo O che cosa
vuole fare con noi se vuole veramente
svuotarci e metterci come soprammobili
Forse è meglio se usciamo fuori di casa
e controlliamo se ancora qua fuori
Concordo andiamo a controllare
qui vicino e magari riusciamo a trovarlo
sarà qui in giardino o all'entrata
È tutto buio non vedo niente
Forse è all'entrata andiamo a
controllare Allora andiamo il nostro
Fedele aiutante
Che cos'è tutto questo baccano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Stanno bloccando la porta di casa
l'uscita non ci vogliono fare uscire Ma
perché Che cosa gli abbiamo
fatto forse perché volevo fare il
risotto con la zucca si sono arrabbiate
entrare nella loro casa e prenderne
possesso
[Musica]
dentro
abbiamo fatto dobbiamo
trattarli come loro trattano noi rari
immergere ancora il riso volevo una
zuppa Io inizierei dal distruggere tutto
questo cameretta
distruggere i giocattoli ormai divertite
tutto quanto
lo sapete benissimo che non possiamo
decidere noi cosa fare Dobbiamo
aspettare gli ordini già
[Musica]
Guarda si stanno muovendo aiuto cambiamo
andiamo
C'è mancato poco hanno bloccato il
passaggio Chi ha chiuso la porta qua No
ero davanti a te
Ah ah ah ah
Ma che cosa stanno facendo le zucche
Ahia
Giochiamo giochiamo
Mmm Adesso cosa facciamo
Aiuto Si sono appropriati della nostra
cameretta e del corridoio non possiamo
più uscire fuori di casa Ho un'idea
dobbiamo trovare un piano per mandare
via le zucche dalla nostra cameretta e
dalla nostra casa Se ci nascondiamo tipo
se prendiamo un lenzuolo tipo questo ce
lo mettiamo addosso così magari loro
pensano che sapevamo dei fantasmi e ci
lasciano stare perché magari il fantasma
più fa più paura della zucca No ma
sinceramente non mi sembri proprio per
niente Un fantasma con poterlo addosso
faccio così neanche sembro fantasma Sì
ma se non hai i buchi per vedere come
fai a vedere dove vai
ma attento
no Ferma c'è l'armadio lì
Ahia aspetta oh ho perso le antenne Ecco
perché non mi orientavo
questo mi prendono un segnale
satellitare quindi vi dirò bene quindi
non va bene guarda
Secondo me questo piano non funziona
però la tua idea di mettermi contro
l'armadio di trasformarti in qualcosa
potrebbe essere un buon piano ad esempio
di che cosa hanno paura le zucche
del risotto
del forno
vero che abbiano paura del forno ma non
possiamo portare il forno là dentro e
metterle dentro il forno starebbe
impossibile e poi hai visto quanto sono
grandi vogliono quelle zucche giganti
potrebbero schiacciarci quindi dobbiamo
trovare un piano che funziona Ho avuto
un'idea E se tu ti travestiti da uno di
loro Oh Ottima idea e se poi mi prendono
saranno che sei uno di loro Quindi
basterà che tu ti travesti da zucca fare
finta di essere uno di loro così le
convincerai ad andarsene via Oh direi di
capire quali sono i loro piani oppure
individuerai questo Jack il re delle
zucche andare via lui e penso che se va
via il capo andranno via tutte giusto Sì
giustissimo e mi chiamerò sarò la
recluta zucca mi chiamerò zucca nuova
oppure testa di zucca Sì la nuova
recluta ho paura che questo nome possa
offenderli quindi Scegli un nome più
appropriato zucca dura e scrivete voi il
nome che dovrà utilizzare evitare quando
si travestirà da zucca Ok iscrivetevi
giù nei commenti